we're asked at which points on the graph
is f of x times f prime of x equal to
zero so if I have the product of two
things and it's equal to zero that tells
us that at least one of these two things
need to be equal to zero so first of all
let's see are there any points when f of
X when f of X is equal to zero so we're
plotting f of X on the vertical axis we
could call this graph right over here we
could say this is y is equal to f of X
so at any point does the Y value of this
curve equal zero so it's positive
positive positive positive positive
positive but it is decreasing right over
here what's decreasing here then it's
increasing then it's decreasing and it
does get to zero right over here but
that's not one of the labeled points and
they want us to pick one of the label
points or maybe even more than one of
these label points so we're going to
focus on where an f prime of X is equal
to zero and we just have to remind
ourselves what F prime of X even
represents F prime of X represents the
slope of the tangent line at that value
of x so for example F prime of 0 which
is the x value for this point right over
here it's going to be some negative
value it's the slope of the tangent line
similar similarly f prime of X when X is
equal to 4 that's what's going on right
over here that's going to be the slope
of the tangent line it's going to be a
positive value so if you look at all of
these where is the slope of the tangent
line 0 and what does a zero slope look
like well it looks like a horizontal
line so where is the slope of the
tangent line here horizontal well the
only one that jumps out at me is point B
right over here it looks like the slope
of the tangent line would indeed be
horizontal right right over here or
another way you could think of it is the
instantaneous rate of change right at
right of the function right at x equals
two looks like it's pretty pretty close
to if this is x equals two looks like
it's pretty close to zero so out of all
the choices here I would say only B
looks like the derivative
at x equals 2 or 1 or the derivative or
the slope of the tangent line at B it
looks like it's 0 so I'll say B right
over here and then they have this kind
of crazy wacky expression here f of X
minus 6 over X what is that greatest in
value and we have to interpret this we
have to think about what is f of X minus
6 over X actually mean
whenever I see expressions like this
especially if I'm taking a differential
calculus class I would say well this
looks kind of like finding the slope of
a secant line whenever in fact all of
the all of what we know about
derivatives is finding the the limiting
value of the slope of a secant line this
looks kind of like that especially if at
some point my Y value is a 6 here then
this could be the change in Y value and
if the corresponding x value is 0 then
this would be f of X minus 6 over X
minus 0 so do I have 0 6 on this curve
here well sure when X is equal to 0 when
X is equal to 0 we see that f of X is
equal to 6 so what this is right over
here let me rewrite this this we could
rewrite as f of X f of X minus 6 f of X
minus 6 over over X minus 0 X minus 0 so
what is this what does this represent
well this is equal to the slope this is
equal to do submit color this is equal
to the slope of the secant line secant
line between between the points between
the points X f of X X and whatever the
corresponding f of X is and and we could
write it as 0 f of 0 because we see f of
0 is equal to 6 this right over here is
f of 0 in fact let me just write that as
6 and the point 0 6 and the point 0 6 so
let's go through each of these points
and think about
the slope of the secant line between
those points are and point a this is
essentially the slope of secant line
between some point X f of X and
essentially Point a so let's draw this
out so between a and B you have a fairly
negative you have a fairly negative
slope remember we want to find the
largest slope so here it's fairly
negative between a and C it's less
negative a and C it's less negative
between a and D it's even less negative
it's still negative but it's less
negative it's less negative and then
between a and E it becomes more negative
now it becomes more negative and then
between a and f it becomes even more
negative it becomes even more negative
between a and f so when is the slope of
the secant line between one of these
points and a the greatest or I guess we
could say the least negatives because
they're always there it seems like
they're always negative it would be
between point D and a so when is this
when is this greatest in value well when
we're looking at Point Point D at Point
D X is equal to 6 X is equal to 6 it
looks like f of X is like five and a
half or something so this will turn into
f of f of 6 which is five and a half or
maybe it's even less than that five and
a third or something minus six over six
minus zero that's how we'll maximize
this value this is the least negative
slope of the secant line